壊れる壊れるものの代わりに何か作ってつなげてくれる
壊れたものは全てつなげて作ってくれるんだったら
人間は全く同じ状態でいるんだけど
そうはないんだけどね
そうはないんだけど とにかく壊れる
いつでも壊れていっちゃいます
物質は壊れてるたびに新しい物質はつなげて
とにかくつなげてはくれる
同じ形ではなくても ですから赤ちゃん産まれるんだけど
死ぬ時は老人なんですけど
でもつなげてはくれてるんですね
それは続く 進みますよということなんです
ですから 老人が死んだところで犬になっても
仏教からはあれは信じられないということじゃないんです
別に犬の形になったっても
それは別に大したことなくて
つなげてはくれてるんだから
同じことですよ 赤ちゃんの写真と死んでる老人の写真ね
その一緒に比べてみたら変でしょうに
人の葬式に写真飾ったりでしょうよ
その時はその人の赤ちゃんの時写真飾ったらどうですか
その時みんな変だと思っちゃうでしょ
それ当然変なんですけど
でもそれもつなげてるということで
ですから私は過去世で犬でしたとか
牛でしたとかいうのは決して不思議ではなんでもないんです
それ不思議だったらね
もう死んでる老人の葬式でね
赤ちゃんの写真見て ああ
これはまで不思議と思いますか
ということで 心は次のことにつなげると
で それはもうちょっと説明
ちょっと合理的に科学的に持っていっちゃうと
心っていうのはもう何か働きなんですけど
働きだから止まってないもので
波として説明できるんですね
で もしある波があって
その波に波が続けるエネルギーはずっとある場合は
その波は限りなく続けるでしょう
何でしたっけ？ニュートンさんでしたっけ？もうそういう人々の法則から考えたっても
例えば私は何か球を投げたところで
それは永遠に転がっていくはずなんですね
誰かからこの他の 何て言いますか
あれはレジスタンですか
この違うエネルギーで変化しない限りは
そう同じく心の場合は
このエネルギーが生まれたと言ったならば
そのエネルギーは次から次へとつなげる
エネルギーが消えると
またそれに支えてくれるエネルギーがいつでもあるんですね
ということで 心の波は消えなく消えない
そこ難しいんですが 一応心っていうのは波として見ると
仮定して波です その波は我々知っている水の波だったら
他の何かにぶつかってそこで止まっちゃうんですね
ぶつからなくても波一つ作っちゃったら
そのエネルギー場は消えたところで止まっちゃうんです
そこで波に似るのはエネルギーを吸収されることだけなんですね
吸収されちゃうとエネルギーは消えて波も消えちゃいますけどね
吸収される機能だけじゃなくて
また補助する機能もあっちゃったらどうなるんですかね
波は消えないんですよ
ですから 例えばモーターで水の上で波を作っちゃうと
作る作る波は消えるんだけど
モーターからまだ新しい波を作るんだから
ずっと波が流れていくようになっちゃうし
じゃあそういう法則で心っていうのは波であって
波にはいつでも続けるように補助しますね
エネルギーが そうであるならば
波だから消えて現れている法則でしょ
もう波の場合 そこはあまりわからないかもしれませんだけど
仏教の世界では生と滅ですか
えーと 何でしたっけ 全部忘れてあれは
ちょっと 名前が思い出せないから
ちょっと何でしたか 思い出せないな
ちょっとパーリ語は思い出せませんけど
これ生と滅と現れて消えて
現れて消えて 現れて消えるというと波なんですね
で そうすると心が現れたらすぐ消える
消えたら次に現れるしかないんです
で 消えたところでエネルギー補助しなくなっちゃったら
もう どこかでエネルギー補充をやめちゃったら
持ってるエネルギーでは現れて消えて現れて消えていって
やがて消えちゃったら
もうそれで消えたということになりますけど
でも普通の心というのはいつでもエネルギー補充がずっと続けるんですね
そういうことで 人は死んでも
もう人であろうが何であろうが
もう機能だから 心っていうのは一つの働きだから
消えるっていうことは
次の新しい形で現れるため一番ベストなベストコンディションなんです
いわゆる一つ消えなきゃ次のものは現れない
ですから 消えるっていうことは
次の現象を現れるためには必要条件なんです
ということで 死っていうのはもう次の結晶のために必要な条件で
何も不思議もないんですよ
仏教の世界では人が生まれ変われるっていうこと
人っていうのはおかしいんだけど
生命が 生命っていうのはおかしいんだけど
心の波 心の波動っていうのは続くっていうことは何の不思議もないこと
物質はそういう風に変えて変えていくなのに
物質は鈍くて分かりやすくて
もうそんなにエネルギーを持ってないのに
物質は支配している心は死んだらそれで終わりますよというのは
もう何もわからないだから言うだけで
ちゃんと合理的に見ると
これはそんななるはずがないと分かります
まあそこはそこら辺の説明やりますけど
あの 自分をこちらで一般大衆で言いたかったのは
我々は死んでまた生まれ変わる
その場合は原因になるのは私は持っている心なんです
神様はもう一つチャンスを与えてくれたわけじゃない
転生はカトリック教でもあちこちでも今信じるようになってますけど
ヨーロッパでもね でもそのヨーロッパで信じている輪廻転生と仏教でいう輪廻転生はもう全く違うし
そこはもう魂がまた現れるということであって
まあそれは心がまた現れると言ったっても同じことですけどね
それは言葉だけかもしれませんだけどね
大体そちら辺ではね なんとかなんか神様がね
またチャンス与えてくれたと
一回の人生で全て決めるのはなんかちょっと難しいではないかと
ですから人はもう何回何回ももう頑張ってみて
それでまあ結果を出すということで
輪廻転生を考えてるみたいですけど
で  今何時ですか うん うん
まあ一応一つの心の働き
結晶すること で 生まれ変わるとか何とかとか場合は
心はもう 一番大事な働きをしている
生きる時でも一番大事な仕事をしているのは心なんですから
ですから 別に不思議な言葉で扱っているわけじゃないんです
番目 バワンガ ウブンと書いてますけど
このバワンガという心はどういう心でしょうかね
で そこはこの こういうこと
私たちにはこの目に情報が入ると見る
それについて考える 耳に情報が入っちゃうと
それは聞く それについて考えたり
感受したりする そういうふうにいつも忙しいんですよ
心が 情報いっぱい入りますから
目は開いている時は目に形が入らない瞬間一つもないでしょうに
それで心が活動している
音はいろんな入りますから
それで活動している そういうふうに
常に私たちの心がいつでも情報があって
そういうのは認識するということは必死になって認識するんですね
認識すること自体がこの心のエネルギーなんですよ
ですから 心のエネルギーはずっと補助しっぱなしで止まることはなくなっちゃう
それはそれでいいんだけど
もし情報をカットしたらどうなるんですかと
その人悟りますかね そうだったら解脱しますかね
心 なぜならば心に補助なかったんだから
目から入る情報をストップする
耳から入る情報をストップする
鼻から入る情報をストップすると
それは医学的にもできますよ
麻痺させちゃえば完全に
意識の働きもストップすると
脳の働きも麻痺することできますからね
薬をもって そうするともう煩悩が生まれることもないし
何か心 じゃあそれは解脱ですかと
そこまで仏教で考えてるんです
それは解脱じゃないんだと
ある外教というか 他の宗教の人が来て
お釈迦様と私たちもね
別に違う宗教を教えているわけじゃないんだと
お釈迦様は目で物を見て煩悩が生まれるんだと
耳で音を聞いて煩悩が生まれるんだとか
味わって人は煩悩が途絶えるんだ
嗅いで煩悩が生まれるんだとおっしゃっているし
私もそれはその通りだとおっしゃっているんだと
その煩悩さえなければ解脱ですよと言って仲良くしたかったんですね
お釈迦様 なんか似てるでしょ
教えが 同じことをお釈迦様おっしゃってるんだから
目で物を見て そこで怒りと欲という種類の煩悩の流れが生まれるんだと
それ怒りと煩悩さえ生まれなきゃ
煩悩さえ感情さえ生まれなきゃ
そこで幸福ですよとは言ってますよ
ですから お互いに教えは同じではないかと言ったら
お釈迦様どう答えたと思いますか？すぐ反応したんですね
あ それだったら生まれつきの人が目が見えない
耳が聞こえない 感覚もない
舌の感覚もない そういう完璧な障害で人が生まれて
あの人 あいつは生まれつき解脱してるんだ
と言われたら どういう
これ最悪の状態で生まれたら
ただの肉の塊みたいな感じで
目も耳も鼻も口も何もない
それだったら解脱してるんだと
あんた言ってるのはそういうことでしょうと
と言っても違いますよということになったんです
だから ですね あまり遊べないんです
仏教の概念とは そういうふうに厳密に考えているんだから
で 説明する場合は 我々にとっては
我々知っている煩悩っていうのは
いろんな音楽を聴くと
楽しさやら嫌な感じやら生まれるし
人の話を聞くと舞い上がったり
気持ち悪くなったりはするし
見る時でも同じことだし
食べることだけでも煩悩は生まれますよ
煩悩ない方が悟りだと決めちゃったら
それだったら全部情報をカットすれば悟りではないかと
それは悟りではない ただ情報をカットしただけ
それだったら生まれつき完全たる障害で生まれた方が一番不幸ではないかと
一番幸福ではないかとなってしまうでしょうに
ですから そこら辺で問題は解決しなくてはいけない
そうではないと で 目から耳からこの五根から情報が入らない
それから意識も働かないとする
考えることもないとする
耳から鼻からの情報はないとする
そうしてもそのものが生きてるんです
死んだわけじゃないんだから
そこでまたその人の耳に音が入っちゃったら聞く
機能が活動し始めるでしょうに
例えば医者が我々を完全に麻痺させちゃったところで
自分がいることさえ知らないんです
あの完全全身麻酔したところで
人はもういくらが麻酔かけてかけてくれる状態は何とかぼやっと知ってるんだけど
それから何が起きたかわからない
目が覚めてみたら もうあっちこっちもう体が切ったりして
いろんなものをしてベッドの上にいるんですね
手術のあのオペレーションシアターじゃないんですね
それは一日後とかね 三時間後とか
まあ一応オペレーションシアターから出す前には
この一応目が覚めてくれるかないかとちょっとチェックしますけど
そのままいっちゃいますはまあ問題だからね
そこをチェックして まあそろそろ目が覚めてくれるかなと分かったら
それは厳密にチェックしますけど
この手術自体よりは麻酔の方がすごい緊張するみたいです
いわゆるそれは体に決していいものじゃないんです
一番危ないのはそれなんです
もう体一つ麻酔なくなっても
取ってしまったってまあ大したことないですし
血液だけね まあ止まってもらえば出血だけね
死なないんです あれはもう危ないんです
ですから まあ十分気をつけて
このアネステティストという専門家がね
まあずっとそばにいて
チェックしてチェックして
体の機能をずっと見ているんです
彼が何をこの手術自体を知っている医者よりは
この麻酔かけて それの責任の医者が本当にもう神経使っちゃうんです
なぜかというと この細胞の機能はどう続けているか
続けているかと 血液 あの酸素の吸収ですか
それはちゃんと続けているかないかとかね
血圧はちゃんといわゆる生き続けているかないかと
こんなひどい目に遭わせているんだから
ひどい目に遭わせても生き続けられるぐらいの
このギリギリのところでその人を置いておかなくちゃいけない
これ一時間二時間四時間とか
そこが一番難しい仕事
ですから その場合は本人が何も知らないんだけど
また目が覚めたらまた同じく見えたり聞こえたりする
じゃあ問題はその手術中
その人の心はどうなったかと
心っていうのは聞くこと見ることであるならば
考えることであるならば
その人聞いたこともない
考えたこともないでしょうに
じゃあ心はどうなってるんですかと
止まったんですかと 死んだんですかと
そうじゃなくて その人その間は生き続けたんです
この生き続けたということの心なんです
生き続けたという働きあるでしょ
見たわけじゃない 聞いたわけじゃない
考えたわけじゃない 味わったわけじゃない
触れて触れた感覚を分かったわけじゃ何もない
やったしか-はたった一つ生き続けた
それを有分と言うんです
分っていうのは存在生きることであって
分っていうのはまあただつなげるっていう意味で
だからこの原文パーリ語ではバワンガと言うんですね
バワっていうのは存在
アンガっていうのは まああの鎖の一つに何と言いますか
鎖っていうのはつなげてつなげて出来上がっちゃうでしょ
一個一個あれコマに何て言いますかね
鎖の 環ですかね まあ鎖っていうのは一つ一つ輪をつなげてつなげてあって
それであの見ることは一つの鎖のようなもので
時間かかっちゃう 聞くというものも時間がかかっちゃう
味わうということも一つの大きな働きだから
いくいろいろ長い鎖 一部一部なんですよ
だから見ることも聞くことも全く違う働きだから
鎖はまた違うんです いろんな種類の鎖があるでしょうに
例えば玉々みたいな鎖もあって
丸まるい丸い輪の鎖あって
ぺっちゃんこになる いろいろアクセサリーで見たことあるでしょうね
いろんな種類の鎖があったりする
例えば六種類の鎖があると言ったら
六種類の鎖があるということは
見る流れ 聞く流れ そういうのは一本につなげちゃうんですね
有分心が そちらには何もおしゃれも何もない
形もない ただつなげてくれるだけ
例えば皆様ご存知ですみたいな
このネックレスいろいろありますけど
つなげるのは同じものだけなんですね
この輪が形が同じでないと次から次へとつなげないんです
全く違う形の輪を持ってきたらつなげないんですよ
そうすると一般的な基本的な輪を一つ作って
それはこれにつなげて
これに次の新しいデザインの鎖をつなげなくちゃいけない
だからデザイン二つの鎖が持ってきて
その鎖が一本にしようと思ったら
そのまま一本にすることはできない
デザインが違うんだからつなげない
一応つなげる場合もありますけど
それでこの鎖とこの鎖は普通の輪でつなげられます
どうせ穴がありますから
で 一本になると そういうふうな感じで
我々のいろんな意識の働きを一本につなげる働きにバワンガと言うんです
その説明は難しいかもしれませんだけど
一番わかりやすいのは
何も見ていない 聞いていない時も生きているんだから
心が一番基本的な働きだけして生き続くという働きだけしてるんです
まだ情報入ったら聞く
見る 他の定義で言うならば
心っていうのは生きるということ
ただ生きる命 それはもう時間の流れでずっと命はもう流れていく働きだから
何もしていない そこでその生命というか
生きているというものが何か形に触れたと
それで見るという波が生まれる
それ終わったらまた普通の生きているという働きになる
それで音が入ったらそれを聞いて
それ終わったらまた普通のレベルに戻る
または何か考えること
もっと考えて考えて それ終わったらまた普通に戻る
ここはいつでも生滅生滅する流れで動いています
生滅する流れで動いているんだけど
音に触れたら聞くという流れが生まれて
それ終わったらまた落ち着いてまた流れていく
目に何か入ったら見るということが生まれて
それについて考えて それ終わったらまた落ち着く
そういうふうな働きなんですね
そこでこの基本的な心の働きにはバワンガと言うんです
バワっていうのは存在
アンガっていうのはこの輪つなげるっていうことです
そういうことで 眼耳鼻舌身から情報入らないんだからといって挟まるわけじゃないんです
なぜならば 心は基本的な生滅変化しながら待っているんだから
ただ生きているという状態にいるんだから
情報入っちゃったら すぐそれを認識して煩悩が生まれるんです
それについて 入らない限りはもう手術中みたいに完全麻酔になっちゃってるような状態ではいますよ
何も苦しみもないし 自我意識さえないです
自分がいるんだという自我意識さえこの分離している意識だからね
分離していないと自我意識さえないんです
私がいるんだっていうことは
過去の知識では そこは難しいでしょうかもしれませんだけど
人間の知識ですべての過去の知識なんですね
私がいるんだという今瞬間の実感ないんです
今まで生きてきたこの瞬間の前生きてきたんだから
そこを認識して生きてるんだ
そうするともう分離してるんですね
そこら辺を言いますけど
難しいんですからね 説明は難しいんですけど
で 完全麻酔の状態では分離してないんです
だから自分がいるという実感さえないんだけど
生き続けたことは生き続けたんです
で 我々もこのディープスリープの場合
何て言いますか ものすごい深い眠りに落ちた場合は
いたかいなかったか 死んだか何かもわからないでしょう
その時は自覚意識ありますかね
ないでしょう その時はずっとこのバワンガの心はつなげていくんです
生きてはいるんだから
だからそこら辺もその心だけなんですよ
なんかあそこのヨーロッパの心理学で
この無意識につなげるっていえばね
無意識は全然成り立たないね
アビダンマでは 何で無意識必要でしょうかね
私は無意識っていうのはないと思ってますけどね
無意識っていうのがあるならば
どうやってそれわかるんでしょうかね
かえって 無意識だから
で あの英語で普通に言うHe became unconsciousとかね
それは分かりますよ 意識不明になった状態もunconsciousと言うんです
それは分かります それは正しいんです
なぜならば その本人がその状態わかりませんから
でもunconscious mindといえば
だいたい分身だけでしょうね
それだったら ずっとunconscious mindで我々はね
支配して色々やらせているというと
まあそれはちょっと問題ですけど
でも全く危ないということじゃなくて
とにかく我々の心はこの分身は生命の基本としてずっと生滅生滅しながらいく
それで分身が情報が触れた瞬間で見たり聞いたり感じたり考えたりはする
ですから とにかく我々を見るもの
聞くものはどのように認識するかということは
分身という心次第なんですよ
例えば我々の分身というのはどうにもならないすごい弱いもんだったら
我々見るものの知識も聞くものの知識も大した知識じゃないんですね
人の分身という流れが強烈な流れであるならば
すごい力強い流れであるならば
その人は見るものも知るものも聞くものもすごい知識的なものになるんです
そこら辺圧倒的 くると思いますけどね
ウブンシンだけバワンガチっただけ覚えといてください
つなげる心 で 私たちはいつでもそれ持ってます
完全に眠くなって完全に消えた瞬間でもウブンシンなんですね
夢なんか見る時はウブンシンじゃなくてちゃんとした意識なんですね
波が作ってるんだから
わかりやすい波が  寝てる熟睡してる時に何もわからない
全部意識認識をしないっていうのと
麻酔をかけられて無意識の状態になって何も認識ができない状態と違う
同じじゃない  大体同じですけど
一つ違うところは物質的に情報を受け入れられないようにしているんですね
麻酔の場合は  でもそれをもし麻酔をかけてるっていうものを抜いた時に
よけた時の状態は同じ状態じゃないですか
熟睡して何もわかんない
それは同じです  同じ状態ですよね
ただ その人為的に麻酔をかけているから無意識っていうことは当てはまらないってことなんですか
無意識じゃなくて 我々はウブンシンというバワンガという言葉を使ってるんですね
その時はアンコンシャスというのは正しいんです
その時に限って 私が今文句を言ったのは
この心理学で言ってるアンコンシャスマインドなんですね
心理学の世界で言ってること
例えば人の性格が悪いのは
子供の時はなんとかって
それはアンコンシャスマインドでもうあなたをいじってるんだと
そうじゃなくて その過去で何かあったところで
自分の心の流れが変えちゃったんですね
この変えた流れ流れてるだけ
で 次の働きまではいかないな
もう四時半になりましたから
次の働きはアワッジャナ
日本語で因典という書いてますけどね
アワッジャナという働きっていうのは
それはすごい基本的な働きで
心はこの 例えばバワンガとして命として
ただ生きてるのみであっても
なんか情報に触れたすぐもう情報の方に流れちゃうんですね
認識の方に行っちゃうんですよ
いわゆる無意識の状態にいても
意識 この意識が起こす情報に触れた瞬間に意識を起こしちゃうんですね
いつでももう何て言いますか
レディ状態にいるんですよ
認識を受けるために そこをその心なんですね
で このこういう風に考えてもいいんですけど
例えばこのバワンガという心は一つの流れとして流れていく
その時は外からは情報はない
外から情報はないんだけど
自分でもうただ生命として
ただもうアンコンシャス無意識的にただ生きているだけ
そこで世の中いろいろ出来事起こるでしょうに
その出来事起こったらすぐ心の流れが変わっちゃうんですね
変わって次に あ これどういうものかで見ようと聞こうとする
この強引にこの麻酔かけて人は認識機能を抑えといたっても
その強引に麻酔かけている状態がなくなったら
物質は変化しますから
この抑えられてるエネルギーはどんどん消えちゃうんですね
消えていくと心がもう外の世界を認識し始めちゃうんですね
だから完全麻酔の状態にいても
心はもう認識したくてしたくてもいるんですよ
したくっているんだけど
外から来る情報は全部完全にカットしているんですね
その場合は物質的に そこで物質的に抑えているエネルギーはどんどん低くなっちゃうでしょうね
体にかけた麻酔でも体から出ていきますから
出ていったところでもうすぐ目が覚めちゃう
目が覚める前に一応反応したりはするんですね
大体ほっぺたなぶったりとかいろいろ見ますからね
で 大きな声で人の名前を呼んでみたりとかしますよ
名前を呼んだら人は全然わからない
自分の名前を呼ばれているんだとわからなかったら
ちょっと目を開けてみたりするんですね
そうすると OK 麻酔が消えていくんだとわかって
まあ安全だと 部屋に戻してあげますけど
とにかく心でそういうもので
情報が入る瞬間入ってくると
いや 認識しようというふうなこのことになるんですね
その働きにアワッジャナと呼ぶんですね
英語の言葉は何でしょうかと今少し思います
アワッジナは あの apprehending
という言葉も書いてますけど
英語だったらもっとわかりやすい英語で opening or turning towards と書いてますけどね
opening というのはまあ open ですからね
で 自分の今流れる状態からすぐ open になっちゃうと
その情報に あるいは turning towards
その情報に 方に曲がっていっちゃう
まああの なんていうんでしょうかね
流れているものはね 例えばまあ鉄
鉄の 鉄の粉ですか 流れて流れちゃうと
そこら辺ちょっとでも磁石やらなんとかあったらそこら辺に回っていっちゃうし
そんな感じで まあ何かあったらそこに引かれちゃうということ
その引かれる働きがアワッジナというんです
そこはあるんだから もうすぐ認識が生まれてくる
まあその次にジャヴァナという言葉なんですね
で ダッサナ ダッサナっていうのは見る働き
で 見と書いてます で 次の聞と書いてるのは聞く働き
嗅ぐ働き で 味わう働きと体で触れる働き
そういうのはわかりやすいし
それからあるのはリョジュという
リョジュという心 それはこの
なんて言って 働きなサンティーレン
サンパティッチェナ サンパティッチェナっていうのは受けるということなんですけど
どういうふうに受けるかというと
あの 心はある一定の形で流れてますけど
例えば何か情報入る 音が入ると
その音の影響で変化しちゃうんですね
だからどんな音が入ったかっていうことによって
ある決まってる変化を起こさなくちゃいけない
水が流れていると 我々はその小さな流れだったら石一つを置けば流れの真ん中で
そこで水の流れを変えるしか方法ないんですね
大きな石を置い-入れたらそれなりに変わるし
紙一つ入れたらそれなりに変わる
そんな風にこの入る情報によって心の流れが変わるし
どのように変わるかということもまた決まっているし
ですからサンパティッチナというのはこの情報を受け入れるという意味なんですけど
情報によって心の形が働きが変わるというサンパティッチナ
それからサンティールナでしょうね
サンティールナっていうのは決まることであって
いいものか悪いものか何とかとか決めなくちゃいけないし
この入った情報 その流れにとっては
それでそれは確定すると
その説明は出ましたから
次に出てくるのは即行心ですね
一旦確定したら この入った情報が
例えば目に何か触れたと
触れた情報が自分では人間として自分の目にとってはいい情報なんですね
見たい 見たいというか
見て楽しい情報なんで
嫌なものじゃないんですね
それで受け入れるでしょ
いい情報入ったと いい情報だと確定した瞬間で
それについて心が流れるんです
これは何々さんだ これは私は会いたくて会いたくてしょうがなかった人だとか
いろんな心が流れ出す
流れるんだから その流れる心の流れには即行と呼ぶんです
これはジャワナという言葉で走ると
そこは人間にほとんどコントロールできないんです
すぐ心が走ってしまっちゃう
胃の中 意識の中 例えば目を閉じてあっても
このドアは誰かが開けて閉めたと
我々は目を閉じているんだから見てないんですよ
でも音だけ耳に入った瞬間でドア閉めたと決めてしまっちゃうんですね
あれはこの速さなんで
走る心なんですね 走らなきゃ別に耳に音が触れただけなのに
ドアが閉めたと決めつけて全部終わっちゃうんです
その心が走る心 入った情報によってただ走ってしまう
確定した情報によってもう走ってしまう心にジャワナというんですね
日本語で即行 次に出てくるのはこの可笑縁と書きますけど
ただランマナそのまま日本語にしていますけど
ただヒショエン ヒショエン
で 何の意味か分かりませんだけど
ただランマナっていうのはこの走ってからもうこの情報エネルギー消えちゃうでしょ
で 例えば強烈な音が耳に入っちゃったら
すぐそこに あ なんだ音かといっちゃうでしょ
そこで音のエネルギーが消えちゃったら
我々は落ち着くでしょ
落ち着いたってもなんか音が残ってる状態
耳に 今ひどいすごい音を聞いたと
じゃあ勉強始まりましょうという状態なんですけど
ほんのちょっとまた音のことを残ってるんですね
それはほとんどいつでもあることなんですよ
心の中で そのような働きは
情報の方がもう物が事が起きても終わったんだけど
心にはまだほんのちょっと響きが残ると
例えばもうガンガンどこかに行って音楽なんか聞いて
あ じゃあ終わって じゃあ帰りましょうと
帰ってくる時でも 頭の中でガンガンこの音が残ってるでしょうに
その働きは厳密に分析してまた言ってるだけ
瞬間 瞬間の情報が消えても
もうわずかに心はその影響でちょっと残っているんだと
それを可笑縁という働きなんです
それから最後に死ですね
死という働きも心がするんです
それもある働きなんです
で 死ぬっていうことはどういうことかというと
我々仏教にとって死ぬっていうことは
この厳密な定義がありまして
この物体の中からいろんな心が波動を受けて衝撃を受けて生きてたんですよ
この物体に目があったんだから
視覚のいっぱいあったり
聴覚いっぱいあったり
いろんなもうことして
で これで無分身になっちゃうんですね
情報が入らなくなっちゃう
例えば目が見えなくなる
耳が聞こえないし 心臓も腎臓も働かないし
ですから機能に影響がなくなって
例えばもうそういう状態になったらもう無分身状態なんですね
無分身状態でいても その体から何か刺激がないと
そこで心が無分状態ではいられないんです
波がね 補助しないと そこで
分身状態って危ないんですよ
弱い状態だから じゃあここで波動をするのはやめたと決めちゃって
やめたと決めませんだけど
やめる可能性はいつでもある
やめちゃったらもうその人は死んじゃったんです
ですから ただの分身そのもの心なんですけど
分身の場合はなく一つの心が消えちゃったら
次の分身が生まれる それ消えちゃったら次の分身が生まれる
こういうふうに続けているんですよ
でも分身の場合は 他の外から何も情報もない
ですから ただの分身そのもの心なんですけど
分身の場合はなく一つの心が消えちゃったら
次の分身が生まれる それ消えちゃったら次の分身が生まれる
こういうふうに続けているんですよ
でも分身の場合は 他の外から何も情報もないし
それでこの機能がしないでストップしちゃうんです
このストップになる働きは死というんですね
そうなったらすぐ他の場所で
他のところでまたこの心の波が生まれるんです
ここでできなきゃあっちでやるんだと
で わかりやすいことで
どうしても流れるものだったら
どこかでそのまま流れを続けるんですよ
うーん  いいといえばいいことですがね
まあ心はエネルギー持ってますから
この体では動かなくなっちゃうし
それだったら他のところで動き始めちゃうんですね
それはこのパティサンヒですね
ですから 生まれることも心の働きで
死ぬということも一つの心の働きなんです
分身の状態でいると死ぬ恐れが結構あります
でも体元気だったら やっぱりこの分身が情報を受け
受け売れる このいつでも敏感だからね
体が健康的だったら情報入りますから
死ぬ恐れはないんだけど
もし体も弱くなって体からあまり情報が伝わってこないというと死にます
電位視点からもう何の情報も入ってこないと
全部壊れてるんだと言っちゃうと
分身一人では まあ植物状態で永遠によっていうことにならないんです
植物人間っていうのは
とにかく物質をなんとかなんとか繋げて置いておくんですね
そうすると もしかすると分身でいるかもしれません
あるいは死んでるかもしれません
どっちかわからない  死ということは
その物体に完全に生命としての機能がストップということなんです
それで仏教からは脳死は死か心臓を停止し死かとはわからない
心臓停止は死じゃないんだけどね
それはわかりますけど
脳死はまあちょっとわからないです
心臓の停止は死でないにも関わらず
それはもうはっきりした死だと医学では決まってますけどね
本当は心臓が止まっても
またぶん殴ったらいろんなことをしてまたスタートするのに
科学的にね 医学的に心臓停止が
日本だったらね 心臓停止は死だと決めてますからね
それだったらなんで心臓止まっちゃったらね
電気ショックしたり あるいはね
いろいろ衝撃を与えたりして
また心臓をね 動かせてもらえますかね
科学的に言えば その人一旦死んだんだから
もうまた新しく全部登録し直しとかね
国民登録あーだこうだとかね
まあどっちでしょ まあ心臓止まったらね
全部終わりますから それでは全てが終わる原因になるだけ
で 脳死は問い合わせちゃえば死んですけど
いいんだけど 一応アビダンマでは心のストップは死であります
体のストップは死とは言わないんですね
で 体のストップは死であるならば
お医者さんが完全麻酔にかけたところで死んでいるんです
なぜならば体は動いてないんだから
その時も死とは認めてないんですよね
科学の定義っていうのはそんなにしっかりはしてないんですけどね
仏教では心のストップは死であります
体の機能はそんなに気にしてない
体は機能し続けても 心は停止してるならば死なんです
で その十四種類の働きに心というし
あるいは心がその十四種類の仕事をしています
どんな心がどんな仕事をするかっていう説明は後になりますから
ここら辺で一応今日の授業は終了します
[背景音]